I wanted to
um throw this up on the screen because
because it popped up a couple times this
week uh this one here reads 1960s ladies
no tattoos no nose rings or green hair
um and down at the bottom here this guy
says her penises
um this is this is what we lost here
guys this is what like this is what I
saw in the 70s when I was a little kid
like like I'm a 70s kid right this is
what I saw this
um no tats you know fit no obesity no
short green you know weird hair septum
piercings none of those things there's
another one that showed up my time this
one here like this here was common you
know this is a photograph from the mid
90s and the caption says there were
several girls of this caliber working in
every Cafe and Restaurant this this I
grew up in the 90s and the girls were
hot like I had a cousin that was 10
years older than me and I remember when
her friends would come over and babysit
they were they were gorgeous and when
you're a kid you don't really know but
I'll look back at pictures of when I was
a kid and I'm like no like these were
like skinny fit feminine just really
attractive women and it's it's sad you
don't even you don't see that much
anymore
um yeah like in the 90s I was I was in
Elementary in high school right and um
there was there was a ton of girls that
looked like this in the classrooms it
was it was they are very normal yeah my
cousin was she was like a high school
cheerleader so you can imagine her
caliber friends and they'd come over and
babysit and I was like seven eight years
old I remember my brothers and I'd be
like wow like she's so pretty uh there's
a video too I think it was like an old
return to Kings article where I
originally got the idea but it's like uh
watch like Lynyrd Skynyrd Free Bird live
in the 70s and it's of course they have
like you know eight minute guitar so
it's like a 13 minute video but as but
there's a lot of panting audience shots
and everyone in there is attractive and
fit there's no tattoos no weird haircuts
objectively yeah like North American
like predominantly white people you
don't see that anymore there or even
when I go home like my mom's kept
herself in good shape thank God uh
because you know that that'll mean
she'll age better and it won't cost us
any money my brothers and I but uh her
friends like they're all dumpy and fat
and gross but you look at like high
school yearbook pictures they'd be like
oh these women were attractive back in
the day like how do you let yourself go
so fast
it was like high school was insane like
you know the women were just so cute and
beautiful and you know today when uh you
know you look at girls of that age it's
like what the hell happened I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out